- [clears throat]
- HEY.
WHAT...WHAT CAN I GET YOU?
- HELLO, SIR.
I WOULD LIKE A RUM AND COKE.
- RUM AND COKE COMING UP.
- [groaning]
AHH, HEY.
WHERE YOU FROM?
ALL RIGHT, BABY.
I'M GONNA SEE YOU
ON THE DANCE FLOOR, GIRL.
OH! AH.
- HERE'S RUM AND COKE.
IT'S GONNA BE $8.
- $8, ALL RIGHT, MY GOOD MAN.
LET ME...[exhales]
[screams in agony]
WALLET, YEAH!
- [shushes]
- WHOO!
LET ME--I'MA GOT IT--I GOT IT.
[bleep]!
- OH! SHH!
- AW, [bleep], MY WALLET!
- HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY, COME ON.
- HEY, YOU ALL RIGHT?
- OKAY, I'M--
- YOU ALL RIGHT?
- WHEW!
[laughs]
I TELL YOU WHAT.
THIRD TIME'S THE CHARM, BROTHER.
[panting]
[screams in pain]
YOU WANT SOME HELP?
THERE IT IS.
- YEAH, YEAH.
YEAH, JUST TAKE THE CARD OUT.
KEEP THAT OPEN FOR ME.
CAN YOU HANG ON TO THAT FOR ME?
- WILL DO.
- IN FACT, LET ME GET
A TEQUILA SHOT, BROTHER.
ACTUALLY, MAKE IT TWO, MAN.
ONE FOR ME,
AND ONE FOR YOU, MY GOOD MAN.
[screams in agony]
- ALL RIGHT.
TWO TEQUILA SHOTS
COMING RIGHT UP.
- HOW YOU DOING, GIRL?
ALL RIGHT, NECTAR OF THE GODS
UP IN HERE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GET THAT GOING NOW.
ALL RIGHT, CHEERS.
- YEAH, MAN.
- ALL RIGHT, MI AMIGO.
- CHEERS.
- [screams]
WHOO!
AH!
- IS--LEAVE--
- NO, NO, HOLD ON.
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE WAY
TO SKIN A CAT.
- YOU WANT SOME HELP
WITH THAT?
- HOLD UP, LET ME JUST
TRY TO GET UP IN HERE.
- OH, MY GOD.
- [screams]
- OH, THAT'S--
- OH, THAT'S BURNING MY TONGUE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
- WHAT? AHH.
- I'M GONNA
GET YOU ONE OF THESE.
- YEAH?
- TRY THAT.
- THERE WE--ALL RIGHT.
HELL, YOU A GENIUS.
LET ME GET THIS GOING ON HERE.
OKAY.
- YOU JUST--THERE YOU GO.
- MM-HMM.
- WHOO!
VAYA CON DIOS, MY DARLING.
THAT'S--
- ALL RIGHT.
- WHOO! ALL RIGHT.
MUCHOS GRACIAS.
- YUP.
HEY.
- YEAH.
[grunts]
UH-HUH?
- SO I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOU.
- OH, NO, I'M GONNA TELL YOU
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT.
I'M WORRIED THAT THIS CLUB
AIN'T POPPING OFF THE WAY
IT SHOULD BE! WHAT? WHAT?
[screams]
'CAUSE I--WAIT A SECOND.
[rap song plays in background]
WHAT? UH-OH.
DJ, TURN IT UP!
THAT'S MY TRACK RIGHT THERE.
UH-HUH. WHAT IT IS!
AAH!
HA-HAAAAH!
[grunts]
UNGH! OH!
[laughs]
[trills tongue and laughs]
- HEY, MAN,
A BAR IS NOT THE PLACE
FOR YOU TO BE RIGHT NOW.
- [screams]
WHOO, WHOO.
LET ME--LET ME GET
TWO MORE SHOTS OF TEQUILA.
- UNH-UH.
SORRY, PAL, YOU'RE 86'ED.
- WHAT? HOW?
WHAT NOW?
AND WHAT--THAT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
- LET'S GO, BUDDY.
- [screams]
- BE--BE GENTLE WITH HIM.
- RIGHT THIS WAY.
- AYE! AYE! AAH!
OH, IT HURTS ALL OVER!
HOW YOU DOING, GIRL?
[screams]
- FIRST TIME, I THINK WAS,
LIKE, '87.
IT WAS TWO GUYS
IN A HEAVYWEIGHT BOUT. YEAH.
NO, IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
IN A HEAVYWEIGHT BOUT
THAT THE TWO FIGHTERS
ENDED UP GETTING MARRIED.
- [Spanish accent]
HELLO, MY GOOD SIR.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE TWO SHOTS
OF TEQUILA.
[screams in agony]
COME ON, BROTHER!
WHY YOU GOTTA--
[groans]
OH, MAN, THAT HURTS.